in this continuing almost
never-ending saga of trying to get
coveted relief
passed joe biden has negotiated not with
republicans
but with more moderate democrats to
further restrict who is eligible for a
stimulus check
what if you're wondering great
now that they've negotiated which
republicans are going to support the
bill as a result of the negotiation the
answer is i'm not aware of any
this is democrats negotiating with
democrats
to weaken coveted stimulus just to get
it passed
and either way it doesn't appear as
though republicans are going to support
this
now i know that there are people in my
audience
who will be mad for this critique but
come on guys
2000 now i'm going to get to the
pragmatic piece so just let me let me
work through it
okay here's the just disgusting
frustrating part of all of this
two thousand dollars became 1400 and
when i critiqued that some people wrote
to me and said david
it was obvious from the beginning joe
biden meant we would add 1400 to the 600
to make it 2000. that's not a fair
critique
you're doing a bad critique david okay
then i say well joe biden said it would
pass right away
and it didn't pass right away it's march
and i critiqued that and some people
wrote to me and said david you know
you should have known that when a
president says right away
they don't mean right away they mean
months okay
and now to get the 1400
check the checks are going to phase out
more quickly as income goes up so here's
the changes that were made
under the old plan passed by the house
you get fourteen hundred dollars if your
income is up to seventy five thousand
and it starts phasing down to zero once
your income is a hundred thousand
under the new plan it's just more
restrictive the 1400
starts phasing out and it goes to zero
at
80 grand instead of at 100 grand
so in short in the house version anyone
making over a hundred thousand gets zero
in the senate version that was
negotiated yesterday between
uh biden and senate republicans anyone
earning over eighty thousand dollars a
year
gets zero now do i think that this is a
really dumb negotiation
yes the phase out at 100 000 was fine
but the reality is with a 50 50 majority
in the senate 50 50 with kamala
as the deciding vote in ties democrats
can't afford to lose a single vote
so joe manchin now has power jeanne
shaheen a democrat from new hampshire
who also wanted to restrict the checks
she has power she wants to take the
money
saved by dropping the limit and send
that money to hospitals
okay does it still make sense to pass
this bill
it does in addition to the stimulus
checks the bill has
350 billion dollars for states 130
billion dollars for opening schools
160 billion dollars for vaccinations and
tax testing
an enhanced child tax credit rental
assistance food assistance so
it's important to pass this regardless
and we can't keep
delaying it but is this a really lame
negotiation
where it's democrats negotiating with
democrats and either way republicans
won't support it of course it is
at some point we have to recognize even
though they're democrats
they're very moderate some we would even
say are almost
uh sort of like centrist republicans
people like joe manchin
it's just the reality um and it's not
even that i think it's that important
that people earning 98
000 get a check like it's more the idea
that
we have zero republicans on board it's
an emergency to pass this
and democrats are negotiating with each
other over whether the cutoff should be
80 grand or 100 grand it's sort of like
what are we doing here type of moment
i get that if you make 98 000
you make 1400 bucks in like five or six
days of work this is less about that
it's the big picture of absurdity of how
it hasn't even nearly been only because
of republicans that this hasn't
passed and of course the 15 minimum wage
is just gone from the bill altogether
but we've already covered that and we
knew it now
on the minimum wage i'm getting some
emails
which i support okay i'm getting emails
from people saying david
you know the senate parliamentarian who
decided you can't do the 15
minimum wage in this bill the the senate
parliamentarian can just be overruled
it's not you know people are acting like
oh it would be a massive step to
overrule the senate parliamentarian
okay yeah it would or it wouldn't but
the truth is if you overrule the senate
parliamentarian
and you include a 15 minimum wage in the
coveted relief bill
i just don't think it passes i don't
think joe manchin votes for the bill
and you can't afford to lose a single
vote in the senate right now given that
no republicans plan to vote for it so
i'm just as disgusted as you are by
what's going on don't don't mistake this
for me
not being disgusted in a practical
reality
you they're just not going to vote for
it if it's in the bill it's not going to
pass
even if you override the senate
parliamentarian and put it in the bill
it's not going to get passed now you
could make the argument and i know some
in my audience will
that it's worth it and it's worth it not
passing
to get those democratic senators on the
record saying they're against it they're
already on the record they've said it at
interviews they've they've put
statements out
so you're just slowing down getting
money to anybody
and uh but bottom line is
we've been talking about since november
4th
even with the two georgia senate seats
that democrats took from republicans
you still need to convince joe manchin
that wasn't an understatement that
wasn't just something i said for fun
it's joe manchin and it's gene shaheen
and over the next couple of years
it'll be one or two other democratic
senators as well the answer is we have
to flip more seats
saying primary joe manchin in west
virginia
if you run bernie in west virginia
against joe manchin and somehow
bernie wins the primary then a
republican wins that seat
the the answer isn't to to i mean listen
primary joe manchin if you want i'm not
saying don't
but the solution here is you need more
than a 50 50 majority
uh and then you know we get to the
question of is this the last
and final coveted stimulus our friend
congressman ro connor last week on the
show said
he doesn't think it should be the final
stimulus i would love
to not need another coronavirus stimulus
that's going to be determined by how
quickly cases decline
how quickly vaccinations increase i'm
not seeing an appetite for more
stimulus after this bill is done at the
congress
level although some individual members
of the house and senate do want more
stimulus
this may actually be it and it would be
great if nothing else was needed
but that's just a it remains a question
mark
send me your thoughts about all of this
negotiation you can find me on twitter
deepakman what if you could read 10
books in just one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what
they do is take thousands of popular
nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently checked out the
book podcast marketing strategy by
daniel rolls
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing really recommend it blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video